when league of legends newest champion
akshan was announced on july 7th
the community erupted about him having
what looks like
the most broken ability the game has
seen in
years it's supposed to be a normal move
but it's really not in fact it might be
completely
busted possibly making ax shaan the most
broken
champion the game has ever seen and
people
are pissed
if you love the game you play you'll
always want to know what's
overpowered so you can either play it or
avoid it
well we're always trying to let you know
what's gigabusted here on don't have me
so make sure you subscribe to the
channel
and you'll always be one step ahead so
on july 7th
riot announced league of legends 156th
champion
aksharn i know you had other plans for
me shadya
but i choose vengeance
almost immediately streamers began
reacting to what appears to be the most
broken ability
for years if that champion gets released
the game's dead
i'm sorry i'm going to go variety stream
i'm no joke i'm not even joking
that's not it's not like that's actually
scary are you [ __ ]
what oh dude
i need i need some alcohol now for
league fans a new champion that looks
ridiculously broken
isn't really something new the last two
champions gwen and vigo were
lambasted by the community upon their
release for having pretty overloaded
kits
a trend that applies to most new
champions released over the last few
years
and while action hasn't been released on
public service yet
he might make the other busted champions
look totally fine
in comparison on july 7 an official
league of legends account tweeted out a
breakdown of axsharn's abilities
at first it just looked like a regular
announcement
his passive was pretty normal he gets a
shield after three attacks
after which he fires a quick second
attack or gets movement speed if he
doesn't use it
pretty normal so far arguably a bit
strong
his q is literally just a boomerang that
keeps going if it hits enemies before
returning to akshan
now it's his w where [ __ ] really hit the
fan
i'm gonna read it out first and then
we're gonna break down why people are
getting
so worked up about this w going rogue
passive when enemy champions kill one of
akshan's allies
they are marked as scoundrels when he
gets a takedown on a scoundrel
he gains bonus gold all allies killed by
the scoundrel are
resurrected at their base and scoundrel
status is removed
okay okay let's put this in simple terms
when action kills an enemy that has just
killed his
teammates those allies are then
instantly resurrected in their own base
oh and the move also has an active which
camouflages him to the enemy team
nice on the surface this seems
absolutely broken
in league of legends when a player dies
they respawn
after a death timer early on in the game
it's not that long but towards the end
of the game the death timers can be over
a minute long
if you and your teammates die at this
point in the game the enemy team has
a lot of time to take objectives or even
just straight up
end the game with axan on your team
though this ability
has the potential to resurrect everyone
you can get straight back into the game
to stop the enemy team from
well winning end stage fights like 40
minutes
if action gets you know if someone kills
two of your teammates and then an end
stage fight you you kill that person and
two of your teammates rez
you might get baron or elder it's
difficult to understate just how strong
this could be when you kill an enemy in
league you get gold to upgrade your
items
and you also deny that enemy player from
getting gold and xp
while they're dead now action is
currently available on the test servers
and players like i keep it taco have
shown the benefits of
constantly being able to revive your
fallen teammates
oh god
oh god uh
wait i brought my teammates back to life
okay wait draven you're coming back to
life too dude
now there's another important angle to
talk about here too
league has been around for over a decade
at this point
and over that time riot have released
progressively more
intricate champions over the years now
this isn't a problem in itself
players enjoy more complexity up to a
point there's undeniably more room for
skill expression now
than there was in 2011. it feels good to
start off as a scrub on an intricate
champion and
slowly master it that said the problem
is those champions from the game's early
days
have been basically untouched since
their release and they're now fighting
alongside
champions like akshan who have abilities
they could only dream of
now riot has successfully reworked some
of these older champions but there's
still plenty of them out there that are
just stuck in the past
and the community was quick to point
this out on twitter bretopolis retweeted
akshan's team revivability and simply
said
teemo presses w and walks faster
which is yeah i mean that's literally
one of teemo's moves
other people pointed out that udi has a
similar move that just makes him move
quicker and then stun someone when udi
started dominating in pro play earlier
this year with an incredibly simple
kit we even made a whole video about it
because these old champions just
rarely see the light of day in
professional play
laughing here is yoshi because he locks
into you dear oh
we're doing it all right if you compare
these more simple champions to akshar's
ability to
instantly revive his fallen teammates
you can kind of see why people feel
there's a little bit of an imbalance
here
don't get me wrong there are plenty of
strong abilities in league of legends
but they usually say for a champions
ultima a long cool down ability that has
the potential to completely change a
team fight
bang is hiding he's coming back looking
to come in here comes your initiation
oh my will god
them all and skt with a hell of a
response
will take down four not only is action
reviving teammate
not an ultima it's not even a move
it's a passive the player doesn't have
to do
anything except stay alive and kill the
enemy that just killed their teammates
with his other moves his e ability lets
him swing around terrain which does look
pretty fun
and his ultimate allows him to fire a
locked-on hail of bullets
kind of like a mix of a caitlyn and
luciano which he can also cast
while swinging but it was that team
revival ability that
really got people worked up on social
media completely overshadowing any
discussion of his other moves
now on the flip side axon doesn't appear
to have too much mobility and lacks
any cc at all that's the ability to
impair
an enemy's movement this was something
that ls and nemesis discussed in their
video on action
as well as the potential for him to be
let down by poor
base stats that's the raw numbers of a
champion strength before you take into
account their abilities
his base levels being really bad even
further
means that if he falls behind it's
terrible
a dependency on items is never i think a
healthy design
at all this is very unique unique
is certainly one way to put it but this
quest for champion uniqueness
is something that other people feel riot
have put way too much focus on
back in january 2019 former pro meteor
summed up this sentiment
perfectly on stream i just think a lot
of the time when ryan makes their
decisions
it feels like they don't think about
like will this make the game
fun it's like guys what do you mean a
champion that can't get gold
can't auto attack can't ever rise
oh it's so different oh god my nipples
oh and then they make it and you get in
game you're just like
dude this is [ __ ] in ls's video he went
on to say that he doesn't think the team
revival ability
is as overtuned as community thinks and
that his lack of cc
and fairly weak mobility means that we
won't be seeing akshan very much in pro
play at all
and even if we do there are those out
there that don't see that as a problem
c9s perks admitted that aksharn does
look broken
but that he welcomes the challenge he
said contrary to many beliefs i believe
broken slash interesting kits are what
makes league fun
and more challenging to play slash keep
improving
bring it on action but he did also agree
with a reply about the team revivability
being unfair saying
yeah that sounds a bit too crazy perks
has a point though when we look back to
the early days of the game
the champions were a lot more simple and
the gameplay was
simpler as a result while the map has
stayed largely the same over the years
the item changes and new champions have
driven the game to become more complex
over the years
and there are people out there that
agree with perks that makes it more
fun and challenging but as we've seen
throughout this video
there is a balance to strike here at the
end of the day we're gonna have to do
what we always do when a new champion
gets announced and people go off about
how broken it is
we're just gonna have to wait and see
okay okay let's break this okay
okay okay you know one time i was
playing
maybe this can be for an end board i
just remembered it i was gonna tell you
devon
one time i was playing one of those like
you know guess who games with my grandma
and i said yeah all right we'll leave it
[Music]